hey friends what up I know that we are a
third of the way through 2023 but I
wanted to go back and revisit 2022
because something rather auspicious
happened and I made a long time personal
financial goal by eclipsing my income
back when I was working in the nonprofit
sphere with my income now as a flow
artist which I think is pretty cool Drex
here from drexfactor POI sharing with
you the love of poi spinning and flow
Arts to benefit your body and brain and
today I'm talking a little bit about the
finances of flow and specifically my own
but before we dive in I want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinski and Becca
thank you both so much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission
so some of you know this not all of you
do but just to State it for the record
uh being a flow artist is my full-time
job I should say it's really more than
my full-time job because I very rarely
work only 40 hours a week doing it but
um that has also come with it some
interesting Financial pressures because
of course there isn't an industry built
around flow Arts the same way there is
around say like sports or music so
finding a way to make a living doing it
can be kind of a challenge I love
traditional employment roughly a decade
ago and at the time uh it really was
questionable whether I was going to be
able to make a livable income doing flow
Arts when I left I honestly thought that
for the most part I was going to be
making a living as a freelancer
specifically programming and web design
gigs and that that would subsidize my
work and flow I've experimented with a
number of different income models over
the years but finally found something
that balanced out both my desire to
create content as well as my need to
have an income that would keep a roof
over my head through all of this
and I think I can happily say I've found
a lot of answers to that question and in
the year 2022 I pulled in 48 thousand
dollars for the year as a full-time flow
artist which is kind of awesome a
because that's actually more money than
I was making back in the nonprofit
sphere when I had a traditional job and
also because well it puts me above the
median income in my area for the first
time ever as a flow artist so I must say
I'm pretty proud of that and I want to
share with you all how I did it where
exactly all my different sources of
income were coming from to add up to
that hole all right so I'm going to list
off sources of income here going from
the smallest percentage to the greatest
percentage of my income for last year
starting off at 2.3 K is affiliate
income basically every time I give you
one of those codes in one of my
performance videos to go use to get a
discount on your order that is income
that comes straight to me as basically a
commission on the sale for having done
the recommendation right this is a lower
number than affiliate sales were last
year for for some reason
affiliate marketing seems to be
declining somewhat and I've seen that
Trend continue this year as well but uh
yeah it was still a not unsizable amount
of income I mean that was basically two
months worth of rent for me so I'm I'm
not going to turn it down right coming
in at just over 5.5 K our course sales
now I've long offered passive courses
through mylearning site at
learn.drexfactor.com
basically think of it as like a
structured series of tutorials rather
than just the one-off tutorials I do on
my channel
um those have been a Dependable albeit
meager source of interest for me for
many years now what really changed here
was I started offering live stream
courses that is uh people could sign up
to come learn from me uh by live
streaming every Tuesday night and that
was a runaway success in 2022 uh
probably the biggest boost in any one
source of income that I had last year
and a big part of what pushed me to the
final number for the year next up at 7.2
K is AD Revenue this takes two forms one
of these is AdSense revenue from YouTube
that is if you've watched any of my
YouTube videos and you get a pre-roll ad
uh you know having watched that I get a
portion of the money that the company is
paying YouTube to show the ad which is
great
also for the first time I qualified for
reels bonuses over on Instagram so
Facebook having seen that people were
getting paid on tic talk decided to do
the same thing over on Instagram and I
signed up for their reels bonus program
that wound up being like one or two
hundred dollars a month it wasn't that
much but hey every little bit helps
right next up coming in in an even nine
thousand dollars of income for 2022 are
sponsorships uh sponsorships are when a
company pays me to feature their product
in one or more of my videos sometimes
this will take the form of a tutorial or
instructional video or sometimes it'll
take the form of a company paying me to
use their POI in a flow video if you've
seen any of my flow videos that are more
formally shot around DC featuring flow
toys Ultra POI or fire mechapoi those
are all sponsored videos and legally I
am required to disclose that so uh it's
pretty easy to tell when that's the case
9000 is definitely a new high for that
and that came about as a result of
working with multiple companies on
multiple projects and I think I can
actually do better than that in 2023 so
we'll see and finally coming in at
roughly twenty three thousand six
hundred dollars for 2022 is patreon
now this is the first year that I've
reported my income that patreon has
fallen below 50 of my income now this
doesn't mean I was making less money on
patreon uh in fact I made more money on
patreon in 2022 than I did in 2021 but
it has been a long-standing goal of mine
to get patreon under 50 of my income
specifically because I want to kind of
hedge my bets there's a lot of risk in
having just one income stream be
responsible for like that huge portion
of your income I wanted to make sure
that if anything should happen that if
patreon should change change their terms
of use or what have you that um I would
still be able to make rent and be able
to feed myself and as of last year
that that goal became realized Azar I do
want to emphasize how important it was
for me to come up with multiple diverse
streams of income in order to make the
number that I did last year it wasn't
just having subscriptions through
patreon it wasn't just uh having a
portion of physical prop sales it wasn't
just offering more educational materials
it was all of these things put together
it was Finding ways to offer products
that would appeal to a lot of different
types of people in order to get the
total income to that level and I will
also say I have now been reporting my
income to you all for a few years and
y'all have been able to see how my
income has grown I think to nearly
double what it was when I first started
doing these videos and that's been both
a blessing and a curse because
um I think that knowing how much I'm
making can give other people out there a
rough idea of what potentially they
could make as a professional flow artist
at the same time I had kind of hoped
that by sharing my numbers it would
encourage more people in the community
that are also full-time flow artists to
be more transparent about sharing their
numbers and it's been kind of
disappointing that that hasn't happened
I've had a few of them reach out to me
privately and tell me that they're happy
to share their numbers but only with me
and I I hate to say it but turning it
into kind of a dick measuring contest
was kind of counter to the spirit of the
thing I wanted people to understand that
there are a variety of ways to make a
living in the flow arts and what
potentially their income could look like
doing that
so I think I'm going to say that as of
this video right here I'm kind of done
with this experiment I've gotten to a
number that I feel really happy with and
based upon where my income looks like it
is paced at for 2023 I'm going to make
more money this year than I did last
year
but being transparent with my numbers
really hasn't had the impact that I
hoped it would in the community so I
think that in future years I'm just
not going to publish I'm afraid so
if you are watching this many many years
in advance just know that yeah
potentially you could make close to 50
Grand as a flow artist in a given Year
too
you can follow the same steps I did and
use the same income streams that I did
and it's possible there's also a variety
of other options out there too and with
that dear friends I'm going to get back
to focusing on making 2023 a really
beautiful Year and I hope that you all
do the same did you get anything out of
this video please make sure to like
comment share and subscribe to help
other people find it to keep the
conversation going and to help my
channel grow this video would not be
possible we're not for the kind support
of all of these lovely people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon they and the people who sit down
in the description help to make this
video and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support and if you out
there watching are not currently
supporter but you would like to become
one you can do that by heading on over
to patreon.com drexfactor POI there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better than
that you'll be helping me out on my
mission of bringing POI spinning and
flow Arts to the whole wide world so go
check that out please and thank you if
you'd like to check out some of my other
videos on the business of flow Arts
including my numbers for past years and
how I achieve them I will go ahead and
leave a link to a playlist of those
videos down in the description as well
as up here on screen if you're watching
on YouTube also if you're watching on
YouTube this top video right here is one
that the YouTube algorithm recommends
based upon your past viewing habits so
maybe check that out as well thanks so
much for watching make sure to get
outside to flow today and I'll see you
the new video real soon
peace